hi there i'm rayne wilson and i'm reza
aslan or
i think i'm reza aslan i'm not sure what
are you doubtful of your own identity
well sometimes yeah i doubt a lot of
things about myself
and i doubt a lot about my abilities i
doubt my
fa i'm basically a person full of doubt
right now and is this a bad thing let's
doubt that's what we're going to talk
about today
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird
and we search for the meaning of life
along the way presented by cast media
and soul pancake
[Music]
so i was uh reading this
u.s religious landscape study um the pew
uh forum on religion and public life in
your spare time yeah am i scratching
up the u.s religious landscape stuff
sometimes what i like to do yeah when
i'm just relaxing i put my feet up and
then i read statistics about
uh the religious landscape of america as
one
does and what did you glean well what i
gleaned
was that 63 of americans
are utterly absolutely
100 certain that god exists
63 okay 90
of jehovah's witnesses believe that 88
of evangelical protestants which all i
have to say to them is
you're gonna let jehovah's witnesses
beat you evangelicals i mean
come on it's a competition it's a
competition for faith yeah they've
where are the mormons on here i don't
see them on this 84 percent
mormons not bad i'm not bad all right
but i guess it's like a lot of certainty
a lot of certainty in certain religious
groups
yeah about the existence of god let's
say just for something to believe in
yeah but i would say you would see the
opposite of the same thing
when you were talking to atheists right
that they are
just as certain that god doesn't exist
they're just as certain in their beliefs
uh as you know the people that they make
fun of uh-huh
it's this issue of certainty that's the
problem right right okay
certainty which can lead to
closed-mindedness
close-mindedness right yeah
narrow-mindedness
and i was thinking about sort of this
concept of
doubt and faith i mean i'm telling you
right now reza like
i'm in kind of doubt right now you know
i'm just
i'm not sure what's next in my life i
mean i'm loving doing these podcasts but
um i i'm kind of in a in a state of like
what does it all mean
so i'm kind of there still but
fine with it yeah i'm okay with it i'm
okay with it
this is what the topic of our show is
going to be about today is this idea of
doubt right and this kind of
breaking through this nonsense that
somehow
uh doubt is the opposite of faith when
in reality
doubt is an integral part of faith it is
for me
right it is for you sure and it is for
our guest
today pete holmes my friend your friend
stand-up comedian star and creator of
crashing long time podcaster kind of
like a like a grandfather figure
yeah grandpa podcast yeah uh he has a
podcast called
you made it weird which i've done and
some of them are three to four hours
exhaust and he doesn't let you pee in
the middle of it oh my god talk for
like three or four hours uh also wrote
an amazing
uh memoir called comedy sex god
um and he like me uh grew up
in a very sort of uh conservative
christian
environment where it was all about
certainty yeah
and it wasn't until that moment of doubt
that he truly began to
explore uh his faith his identity
um and and who he is you know what reza
let's let him tell the story
oh i i was just going to say it for him
should we actually hear him
i've gone over this with you a thousand
times yes
we have guests and we want to hear them
talk pete what do you get what have you
got to say
i don't think he's going to have very
much to say honestly let's see what
happens
i'm so happy that you guys had me that's
real we're really excited thank you for
thanking me
i'm pete peter my nickname is peter
uh i'm a comedian and a podcaster and a
writer
and a and an actor and and a human being
as a kid i think probably like both of
you and probably like a lot of us
i had a very itchy what is this that's
what i like to call it what is this i i
didn't like
the the way that i saw a lot of
grown-ups going around just going like
what this is this
let's let's eat pancakes and we have to
pay the bills and we're going to be
stressed about traffic
and i remember being in traffic or i
remember being at the beach and just
going like
what what we're all in this together
you're here and i'm here like what is
happening and i didn't know
until later that everyone's just sort of
making it up you know i mean
so when people in khakis with keys
and wallets and haircuts and
cars told me what it was yeah
which was the christian story right wait
and i want to
let you know that my heart is soft here
i'm not saying this like you [ __ ] ass
no no
they did what they thought was right
right and they told me that this was
basically
a waiting room for later a test
this is a morality play and i'm going to
be a good little boy just like my
parents want me to be and just like
santa claus wants me to be
and based on my finite time on this
planet
an afterlife of either torment or bliss
would be offered to me
um so that that was what i was told was
going on here so i bit
really really hard i tend to have a very
black and white
mind you went all in i work on that yeah
but i go all in
somebody tells me with authority they
had a building
with windows and and symbols and smells
and
songs and they're like guys we need to
save people
they have a really old story the
greatest story ever told the greatest
story ever told
and it's the religion of my country so
i'm getting all of this identity i
believe
reza aslan told me that religion's first
function is identity right and i got so
much identity
out of that as the youngest child my
brother was sort of
uh living a more normal life he had
girlfriends and went to parties and
seemed to have friends and was cooler
than i was and i was like well who am i
and in this building and nobody's
volunteering nobody cares about church
i was like i care whoo i'm swept up into
it i had so much identity and i bought
khakis and i bought a white oxford
and i got the high and tight haircut and
i lead mustard seeds and i led worship
team and i
went to christian college i was in i was
like this is
what we need to tell people
unfortunately
with all of the beautiful symbolism the
seven-day creation the god
saying it is good um the story of uh
of of jesus these very beautiful things
right
uh mercy grace patience forgiveness
justice beauty
kindness patience grace mercy i know i
said some of those twice but they bear
they deserve twice this is some good
stuff yeah mercy
salvation conversion oh and
and these beautiful parables about jesus
tells the story about the two workers
that work in the field one works from
noon to 9 00 pm and one shows up at 8 pm
and works to nine
and the farmer pays them both the same
these absurd paradox
that belong in buddhism they're such um
non-dual
koans they don't make any sense but this
is the god i'm being told of a god that
loves everybody and gives irrationally
that was my wedding vow to my wife by
the way said i vow to love you
irrationally i know i don't i right i
know i don't
think about it i was there too i don't
think about how i love you i am love
foreign
yeah go ahead also the good stories of
um
god saying you know if if an evil person
is kind to his children how much kinder
is your
heavenly father gonna be i know that
kind of makes some people cringe he's
saying
it's a metaphor is gonna love you right
so i loved all that i was like oh [ __ ]
there's purpose there's a there's a tick
there's a pulse that i can feel
and now there's an image that i can
think about and meditate on this
not meditate literally but like i have a
symbol for what i've been looking for
what is this
somebody stapled to that like an
amendment
like we want to pass a gun control
amendment and then there's also one
that's like and
no more funding for special needs
programs or something
my no more funding for special needs
programs was uh
muslims are going to hell jews are going
to hell atheists are going to help
by the way everyone i knew was jewish i
went to a liberal
quaker school actually but all the kids
there in cambridge were jewish
so i'm like they're all going to hell so
suddenly my heart is being filled on one
hand and being broken
with the other hand and i because i was
getting so much identity first and
foremost and a little bit of that
equanimity from some answers i was also
being squashed like my throat
was being crushed that i had to believe
quietly that dead relatives that i knew
that didn't believe what i believed were
going to hell that my own brother was
going to hell because i knew he didn't
believe what i believed
so [ __ ] and every gay person i mean
take your group yeah
any group that wasn't us was [ __ ] and
we were okay even other christians were
[ __ ]
i mean yes go ahead i got very worked up
about this
no no i hear you because i had a very
similar experience and i think
the word that you didn't mention but
that you keep sort of
going around is this idea of certainty
right i mean i think
you know you like me in a lot of ways
you were searching you were searching
for answers you were looking around you
were saying
this is all so big and vast and
confusing and there's so many different
colors and so many different ways of
being and i'm
but i'm just a kid like i'm not in a
place where i can actually
maintain in my mind the idea that there
are many paths many truths many ideas we
don't know
the answer is we don't know and someone
shows up and says to your
questioning mind oh no we know
i have the answer and here is the answer
and it's
absolutely true and it's absolutely
certain jesus always asks dualistic
questions
and he answers from a non-dual place
that's what i think is buddhist about it
so when someone says how can you know
you're buddha nature from the sound of a
cricket
they're not looking for an answer
they're looking right they're looking
that's a con yeah
similarly whenever jesus is asked why
did you save that goat on the sabbath or
whatever
why did you pick weed on the sabbath he
never
engages them on a dualistic level he
always tells a story like that
that says [ __ ] your dualistic thinking
i'm somewhere else i'm elsewhere but is
that what you were taught when you were
a kid
no what i was taught so to both of your
points one was
a phrase that i use in my book um about
this so i read a book all about it's
called comedy sex god
because those are the three things i
care about most and then i say
church with certainty worship so
somebody did my
my home life i think was pretty normal
fairly normal so it wasn't like this
isn't code
for i was abused or anything but it was
tumultuous my parents still do not get
along i don't i don't know if they like
each other or if they ever have
and they're still together unfortunately
that's my job
they go your parents still together i'll
go yes unfortunately and i was
living in this very weird house very
very weird very
at times unstable and then i had people
saying
male figures let's let's page dr freud i
had like father figures who were
calm and nice and were like here our
answers and hear our stories and
and also here's how to behave to be in
the group and to have the certainty and
to show
that you have the certainty be nice
don't swear don't smoke don't drink
don't have sex and i was like god
god i want to be a good boy i want to be
a good boy for my godfather and for my
fake
pastor father and for all the fathers
just give me a father and i'll please
him right now or a mother
so i was in the church i got married
when i was 22 because that's what you're
supposed to do
because i wanted to move to chicago to
do improv it's very unromantic
but i was like i said to my mother again
paging dr freud i was like what should i
do i'm dating this girl i'm in love with
this girl i was a kid
i and i don't want to live in sin you
know what i mean that was me saying it
it wasn't
my my mother wasn't like you have to get
married i was in
and i was like i want to move to chicago
i was also very codependent and i didn't
want to go alone
so i got married and that and that's
what i did um
seven years of the relationship we were
married for six she had an affair
and then i that sort of cracked the
the idea that i had of god as a
protector
in the way that i understood protection
i was like i thought we had a deal
i'm not gonna smoke drink swear have sex
before marriage i'm not gonna do
anything
fun or whatever i use fun in quotes but
all these things that we're supposed to
think are fun or whatever and then you
still
it was like i was paying the mafia and
they still burned down my bakery
like the hoodlums still burned down my
bakery and i'm like well i thought it
was all this protection money i'm paying
you
but the truth is so you could just say
so i was like well screw this but the
truth is actually a little bit more
subtle than that
because this god wasn't what i thought
he was i was then able to allow in
and have tea with all these doubts that
i had been having
secretly but doubt was looked at as a
sin
so it's almost like it's a crazy world a
lot of people live this way where you
don't want to have dark thoughts i
suppose like you start thinking
something morbid or
morose or [ __ ] up or absurd and you
kind of snap it away
christians have a lot of those that's
like book of mormon flip it off
like a light switch i would do that with
my doubt so it's like
i had friends i'm in comedy for [ __ ]
sake i have friends
dying unfortunately i go to their
funerals
and i'm like they're in hell but i
didn't feel like they were in hell i
just didn't feel it
it was not in line with my intuition
ladies and gentlemen when it comes to
saving time and working more efficiently
it's the little things that start adding
up and hogging time in your day
grammarly premium gives real-time
suggestions on your writing
so you can get to the next item on your
list in record time
i teach writing i drill my students on
grammar
grammarly is the way to always get an a
in my class grammarly premiums clarity
suggestions
help you get your message across quickly
without repeated or unnecessary words
their vocabulary suggestions mean no
more searching for synonyms
which i'm constantly doing in my new
book with the free version of grammarly
you're safe from embarrassing basic
spelling grammar and punctuation
mistakes
but grammarly premium's advanced
time-saving features help you write more
clearly and efficiently
hit send with confidence and get your
point across more efficiently
and effectively with grammarly premium
get twenty percent off grammarly premium
by signing up at grammarly.com
slash milkshake that's twenty percent
off folks
at grammarly g r a m r
dot com slash milkshake
milk shakers have you ever had one of
those ideas that you just don't know how
to get started onto making a reality
uh yes you know that i have many many
times rain
you have about 13 books started that you
haven't finished rather
one day one day listen experts say that
not knowing how or where to start is one
of the biggest causes
of procrastination and not following
through on ideas
and the projects that you're working on
and this is why
we're here to plug this app blinkist app
takes top non-fiction books pulls out
the key takeaways and puts them
into text and audio explainers called
blinks
that you can learn from in just 15
minutes use blinks to learn about
how to tackle procrastination for
instance
what they've done is they've blinked
thousands of titles in 27 categories
blinkist makes it
so easy i can read all these books that
i'm dying to read in just 15 minutes
i've been i've been listening to 21
lessons for the 21st century by that
dude
uh yuval hariri everybody loves this guy
the guy who wrote sapiens
who's got time to read an entire yuval
hariri book not me
not you right now on blinkist there is a
special offer
that's just for our audience you got to
go to blinkist.com
milkshake and you can start your free
7-day trial
and you can get 25 off a blinkist
premium membership
that's blinkist spelled b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t
just like it sounds blinkist dot com
slash milkshake you get 25 off and a 7
day free trial blinkist.com
milkshake get learning folks
but you have a new conception of god
that has been allowed in through this
doubt and now
this god allows for comedy
yeah that's right and and allowed the
comedy that i always wanted to be doing
when i started doing comedy was very bad
comedy
oh
there's a lot of people laughing right
now because this is your podcast like
hundreds hundreds
and you birds there's dozens of people
listening right now well they turned it
off dude
unfunny comedy but what rain is saying
is that in this case
uh you spent a good part of that early
life being told doubt was a bad thing
turn it off you know tackle it back down
right uh that doubt is the opposite of
faith
right i'm sure you heard that a lot of
times right right that
if you have faith then you don't that's
an interesting question um
and then what happens is that doubt
becomes
a a creative thing for you it like it
unleashes
things for you i almost called my book
lose your faith
in big letters and then to find it that
is really what i see is happening is
i thought losing my faith and losing my
wife were the worst things that could
have happened to me
and of course those were the great
sufferings
and the great loves of my life that
softened me and allowed me to be a free
enough person
i needed to get i needed to lose that
certainty that and that ego trip of
belonging to a church i needed to burn
it
to the ground and i was briefly an
atheist
mostly because i didn't think about it
anymore and i was like well i guess i
don't believe in god
and then i took um mushrooms and i don't
think everybody needs to take mushrooms
but that was very important for me
mostly because sometimes people tell me
this they're like i don't understand i
took mushrooms and
i just saw a clown and he slapped me for
four hours and i'm like
it's not what you see it's that you see
that with which you're seeing
you see that your brain is constructing
reality from a large innumerous series
of stimuli
and something inside of you is sort of
constructing that
and then there's something witnessing
that construction so
your witness doesn't change on mushrooms
you're still there looking at it
but everything that you see changes so
what remained you know what i'm saying
moods come and go emotions come and go
wives leaves faith leaves what clowns
come and go
that's right what stayed what was seeing
the clown this is the beginning of soul
awareness as you're like
you're seeing a show and mushrooms go
all right this [ __ ] sure thinks
he's pete
walking around buying a sandwich eating
a sandwich
what if we show him a clown and it's
it's not even real but like
can he get into that impersonal
unborn stillness that's watching the
clown
can i psycho analyze you for a moment
please i think it's interesting that you
went
from sort of certainty about
the christian path uh
to certainty that it was false right
that you did flirt with atheism for
for a while there because it seemed like
again i like the way that you put it
that it just seemed like the
the the obvious next step and i feel
like
there is something really fascinating
about
that experience because it's
it's this idea that the the path of
unquestioned belief and the path of
unquestioned disbelief
spring from the same place the desire
for certain psychological things right
for sure
yeah i took mushrooms and hadn't
experienced that i could not articulate
right not just like you could you know
hit your head surfing and have an
experience you couldn't articulate i'm
talking about like a prolonged
five-hour dream that was very important
and very real to me
and i had the thought while i was on my
journey
i'm gonna have to talk about this and
ruin it so
it's it's like terence mckenna says
there is a realm that you can't put into
words
it's just so damn hard to talk about
right so i started to open there was a
softening so that's what faith
is this is richard rohr faith isn't
believing unbelievable things or
pretending that you believe
unbelievable things it's a softening
it's an openness
it's a willingness for something to
communion with you and pass through you
that is freedom itself that you can't
you can't
tackle it to the ground i know you'd
like to and sell it like cbd oil you
can't
it's it's freedom itself you can't even
seduce it
it's doing what it does that's what
thomas burton says you can't seduce
freedom itself when you're talking about
enlightenment or conversion
you can't be good enough to have it show
up it's gonna show up when it's gonna
show up
you can just be willing what's what is
the relationship between freedom
and doubt doubt is a part of the freedom
that i enjoy
freedom to move in sort of any direction
but i'm talking about in
interior reality people who are
physically
disabled meaning they can't move can be
free
people in prison can be free i'm talking
about like an internal
world where you aren't thinking about
freedom you're not thinking about what
you can and can do
you're getting in touch with the
fundamental beingness
that you are that's observing the story
of rain
and observing the story of pete and when
i'm in that place
detached from my emotions detached from
things going my way
detached from my ability to get what i
want and do what i want and see what in
the world
i am freedom that's the freedom i'm
talking about maybe liberation would be
better
or salvation or conversion or being
that's what i believe god is being
itself i believe
thomas aquinas said that there's a way
to say it in latin and that sounds
really interesting
god is being which sounds very new age
can you say it in latin
i don't know how to say goddess est
beingis
i know latin the definition that got me
back into god was joseph campbell's
which is that god is a metaphor
for a mystery that absolutely transcends
all categories of human thought
including being and non-being
so we're basically just conceding that
we're dogs trying to understand the
internet
but as barry taylor the road manager for
acdc said
god is the name of the blanket we put
over the mystery to give it shape
so we're just playing with ideas same
side scientists
are trying to photograph it truth
mystics are trying to feel it we're
trying to commune with it we're trying
to vanish into it like a
spoonful of sugar into iced tea we're
trying to lose ourselves and actually
[ __ ] have sex with this thing and i
mean that literally i don't mean my
penis i mean
i want to merge well then that's not
literal
that's metaphorical you're right okay
you're right sexual intercourse i'm
talking about
i would have sex with that god blanket
though i mean if there was a blanket
over an
unnamed thing and it's like god's under
that i would i would literally put my
penis in there
so but when we're starting with
everything we can agree on i start with
this
reality i have that bit where it's a
joke but i sort of mean it when i'm like
people say an afterlife doesn't make
sense and i'm like i think we're getting
ahead of ourselves life doesn't make
sense we all woke up into something that
none of us asked for
and we're acting like don't be stupid of
course when you die it's over
you are proof that things that don't
make sense happen
this is proof i'm so with you things
that don't make sense absolutely happen
that being said i'm open to everything
i'm open to infinite possibilities
including nothing
that's all fine nobody get too worked up
but we are dealing with
god as a metaphor for a mystery what is
that mystery more specifically if we
want to bring a little rom to us into
that we're talking about consciousness
this is one of the things we all agree
on
that the quality of being of awareness
itself of being aware
that you are uh and you are conscious
is the mystery that none of us really
have our fingers on completely
i would say i don't know if we ever will
even if we have ai and all that stuff
it'll still be
a phenomenon and a really interesting
mystery so that's what i'm saying like
in the old testament moses asked god
what his name is and god says i am that
i am.
so this is our yahweh is our first
metaphor for being
this is a very old story about someone
saying i spoke
with being if you've ever had either a
hallucinogenic drug
or a transcendent experience as i have
as well through meditation or
mindfulness or just staring at a tree
and not
thinking for a [ __ ] 15 minute that's
all you need
look at a tree for 15 minutes and don't
think if you have to think say
yes thank you just allow it and thank it
that tree will start to burn like a
[ __ ] old testament bush
i swear to you and that's what jesus is
going around going like
i know you love your rituals i know you
love your identity i know you love your
family
it's one tree it's one bird it's one
vine it's one branch
if you can get in touch with that core
of being this is important that you
are that's the message of christianity
is that humanity
and divinity are together we were taught
that jesus was the special one
that he did it and let's all worship him
and let's all swear that we believe
that he did it but it's right here and
now it's what's looking at your eyes
right now we would call it the holy
spirit the hindus were called the atman
there's a drop of the eternal ocean in
you making you work
that is that is the good news and that
everyone can agree with notice that i
didn't
alienate anyone else's beliefs anyone
else's sexuality anyone else i don't
want i don't give a [ __ ] if you join me
or not
i i'm proud to say that i found a gospel
or a good news that is for everybody
and the way that it comes to us back to
what i was saying earlier is through
great love or great suffering richard
and that's available to everybody that's
why i say that sounds like god it's not
did the new testament get to that man
living on an island
your goddamn right great love and great
suffering got to him
and those things break your ego and
those things make you ask
who is it behind it everything is
changing what doesn't change
what is what is observing the change
that's why my daughter is transformative
to me
she is awareness she doesn't have a
story yet
she she's getting one every day i'm
watching her build it but she is
that is what i believe christ means when
he says lest you be converted and become
his little children
little children are open that is faith
they are seeing
without a story my tree my
property my country bill's truck
bill's wife bill wake the [ __ ]
up the least of these are the greatest
because
that's just another thing to say like
you're not understanding
everyone is god and drag everyone is
already enough everybody is welcome i
don't care if you started working at
eight
or eight a.m you're getting paid the
same and guess what you've already been
paid
it's not later it doesn't eternity
doesn't start when you die
we are hovering in eternity right the
[ __ ] now
i am definitely showing up at 8pm
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey folks uh just so you know this
podcast is sponsored by
better help is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
well a place like better help
can help what they do is they assess
your needs and they match you with your
own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating
in under 48 hours this is not a crisis
line it's not self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be
locally available in many areas the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can get timely and
thoughtful responses
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
so you don't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room with
traditional
therapy therapy has done wonders for me
uh
it has really helped me in my
psychological spiritual emotional growth
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today
that's right so visit their website read
the testimonials that are posted there
daily
and you'll see why people rely on better
help
visit betterhelp.com milkshake that's
better h-e-l-p and join the over 1
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact i don't know if you
knew this rain
but so many people have been using
better help that they're now recruiting
additional counselors
in all 50 states
and better yet there's a special offer
just for metaphysical milkshake
listeners you can get 10 percent off
your first
month at betterhelp.com milkshake that's
betterhelp.com
milkshake start feeling better start
taking care of yourself people
we love you and we want you to be happy
this episode of metaphysical milkshake
is brought to you by
four sigmatic a wellness company that is
well known for its delicious mushroom
coffee and i know what you're thinking
rain
mushroom coffee say what now that's what
i said
and then i made it and let me tell you
something my friend
best coffee i've ever had
not a joke four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is real
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee
but with lion's mane mushroom for
productivity
and chaga mushroom for immune support
does it taste like mushroom
no it tastes like coffee and i love how
it helps me focus
i can get [ __ ] done i've been riding
like six seven
hours a day on this stuff it's amazing i
absolutely feel no joke
i absolutely feel an uptick in my
productivity every time i drink it it
helps me focus
before sigmatic backs their products
with a hundred percent money back
guarantee
love every sip or get your money back
i'm not sending this back we've worked
out an exclusive offer with four
sigmatic on their best-selling mushroom
coffee but this is just for metaphysical
milkshake listeners
get up to 40 percent off plus free
shipping
on mushroom coffee bundles to claim this
deal you must go to 4sigmatic.com
milkshake this offer is only for
metaphysical milkshake listeners it is
not available on their regular website
oh this is this is so special this makes
me feel really excited
you'll save up to 40 and get free
shipping
go right now to 4sigmatic.com that's f o
u
r s i g m a t i c
dot com slash milkshake
and fuel your productivity and
creativity
with some delicious mushroom coffee and
remember if you don't like it
all you gotta do is send it to me send
it to reza
[Music]
you brought up your daughter just a
minute ago actually have
two questions number one uh
rain you have the oldest kid of all of
us so this is probably
most true for man walter all of 14.
i can't even picture 14 my twins
together barely make
14. um i wonder with regard to this
specific issue of faith and doubt that
we've been talking about and as
i mean i know your baby is just like 11
months but
do you do you and val do you talk about
this do you think about this do you are
you consciously aware
of how you want to teach
um your child what faith and doubt mean
and how
how how connected they are together her
name is lilo which is a it's a
sanskrit word i'll teach her never to
say that by the way
don't tell people but it's a hindu idea
it's it means the dance or the play
of the universe so right there is the
only lesson that she needs her father
her father is just the universe that's
what you tell her you're the universe
that's pretty
she is too uh
but i'm i'm just dabbing and she's just
daughtering
and this again it's not dodging the
question she is the great teacher she is
the softening she spilled my coffee
today that
is beautiful like that's [ __ ]
up man you catch yourself cleaning up
coffee my dog is too i catch myself
cleaning up [ __ ] like everything that
comes your way is this is another
opportunity to to remain with being and
to be
present and to realize that paradise
isn't after the [ __ ] is thrown away it's
it's right here
so her name is is a pretty overt
lesson but to say that all of it is a
dance if she wants to be
a fundamentalist or if she wants to be
an atheist it's all
sort of part of the game there's and
that is beautiful and that is compelling
and that is why i feel like when jesus
spoke he had to get on a boat
to sail out to sea a little bit because
the crowd was too big
this is what people transformed people
transform people that's a richard work
right so like i could tell her my
theology
but even as i sometimes listen to myself
speak i'm like this [ __ ] is
making my dicks off you know what i mean
it doesn't always work for me
that's why the coffee you know what i'm
saying i'm trying to like
stay in sort of a manic brain place
where i can communicate this stuff
i didn't notice did you not at all no
not at all you're fun
but you know i will say that um i'm a
member of the baha'i faith and
in the by faith one of the greatest
services
you can do so life is all about service
and what service you're
giving to others uh which is in so many
spiritual traditions and so many atheist
traditions too by the way
but what the greatest service really you
can give someone is i love what you said
and i'm really going to use this is
actually really inspiring to me that
you do comedy to wake people up and give
them freedom and give them joy
and what greater service is there
than to give someone else joy yeah
thank you thank you for the joy thank
you for the joy
uh we're gonna hit you with some
lightning round questions here we go
uh what color is god what color isn't
god
what's your biggest fear pete's biggest
fear
yes pete's biggest fear pete's biggest
fear
and i know this because i see it and i
deal with it
is uh can be vanishing he wants
to be seen he wants to be appreciated
and he wants to be reflected
he wants nothing delights him more than
saying something and it's reflected back
to him
and feeling that like togetherness so i
guess i could say separation
or um uh being alone
being completely broken when was the
last time you ugly cried
i think it's interesting i don't know if
it was ugly but like
we'll be the judge then well i'm not
gonna do
it val and i were having
dinner it was in hawaii
i think that's important because it was
in this like very idyllic situation
and it was this romantic dinner before
leela was born
and there was this band
like a three-piece string band and they
started playing jeff buckley's
hallelujah
and that's what i love about the spirit
and that's what i love about music and
dance and art
and poetry's ability to like get us and
i and that's that's one of the great
things about valerie was i wasn't
ashamed
there was no like i'm sorry about this i
just had like a good i could cry
thinking about it
something about how honest that song is
and the way the guy was playing it there
were all these rich people and nobody
gave a [ __ ] and there was something
weird about that
that is the divine to me it's like a
violin whispering to you
in a room full of people complaining
that the mahi mahi is overcooked you
know what i'm saying
yes like they thought it was the
mahi-mahi and the clean sheets
but it was really that violin and
as christ would say did you have ears to
hear and in that moment i had ears and
it was beautiful
what's one thing you know for sure
nothing the whole point of this is doubt
no i don't know anything no i didn't i
didn't want to say that i don't know all
i know is that i don't know nothing
all i know is that i don't know all i
know is that i don't know nothing
all i know for sure i mean you do
you really don't know yeah you don't you
don't know much
what is your life's big question
what is this what is this
that's never a bad one thanks so much
pete holmes
i wish i had known that was the last one
i would have milked out
we got we got a lot of milking plenty
was milked
don't worry he had
[Music]
wow i did not doubt that that was going
to be a fascinating
conversation honestly really amazing i
knew that he was a spiritual guy i knew
he was a funny guy
but he really blew my mind and i i've
got so much to chew on right now
really really psyched so here's a
question for you
if you were to sort of talk about what
is
the thing that you doubt the most
right now what would that be
that's the thing i always am wrestling
with like am i am i doing it right
am i do am i am i doing what i'm
supposed to be doing
like i'm always in this state of like
why
am i not in the slums of bombay
right now serving the lepers like isn't
really
that what i should be doing isn't all
this
hollywood stuff and deals and roles and
and and sitcoms like shouldn't i
jettison this
really ultimately at the end of the day
if i want to put my money where my mouth
is
sorry that's kind of an estate
for me i guess it would it's kind of
like that for me um
but it's less uh should i be here
or uh helping the poor
on the streets of mumbai and instead
it's should i be the poor
on the streets of mumbai give it all
away give it all away yeah like is it am
i what am i doing am i
am i just creating this kind of
false construct like i guess my doubt
gets so existential that i just
doubt the reality that i am living
in itself so dear listeners
i'm sure you have doubts too please
share
your doubts biggest doubt your faith
your certainty your uncertainty with us
use the hashtag
metaphysical this has been an astounding
conversation
really revelatory we'd love to hear from
you
where are you at with your doubts dear
listeners guess what reza
the questions came pouring in on the old
speak pipe
so many questions i figured you bring up
god and people have things to say
it is it is a popular topic of
conversation an incendiary one
no less i don't think god exists
i am an atheist i think we just all
live and die one day we're all on a
floating rock in the middle of space
and i think that god or the concept of
god
is just the security blanket for people
who
struggle with the idea that you know we
are nothing
we're just super evolved species of
monkeys on a random floating rock
and that's fine you know people can
believe what they want to
to bring them comfort because at the end
of the day we
only have a one very short life and even
though
in the grand scheme of things it's
meaningless the little moments that make
you happy
you should you know cherish and
the little things that do bring you joy
no matter how meaningless everything is
you should do
because you know that that's that's what
we're living for happiness
so you know god might not be real but i
think that it's
it's the idea of just just grasping to
to happiness in the meaningless life we
have
i think that's what god is to some
people and i think it
it varies from person to person
well thank you uh random british atheist
i i thought that was a really lovely
comment because first of all the little
beautiful
golden glorious moments that he was
talking about cherishing
whether you're a theist or an atheist
a hundred percent believe that that's
what life is all about
is those little beautiful moments of
meaning it doesn't matter
if you think there's some kind of
supernatural force
behind this creation or not and i was
going to say in the first half
of his talk i was i was like god if i
felt the way he did i just put a gun in
my mouth
you know it's so depressing you're
sitting in a rock in the middle of
nowhere
and nothing has any meaning and it's all
meaningless nothingness until you die
but then he turned it around and talked
about finding meaning in your life and
and then what i also loved and
appreciated about him
and is it seems so often that
atheists get very triggered by people
that believe in god and he's saying
hey if it gives you meaning if it gives
you hope if that
belief paradigm helps make your life
better then
go for it so he was a very supportive
atheist of people that are on a
different kind of of journey and i
really appreciated that and i think
that's more of the kind of dialogue that
people need around this
topic and you and i reza we both kind of
stay away from like the old debate of
theism and atheism and
it's kind of yeah it's kind of worn out
it's useless and you'll never change
anyone's mind
and i do think finding those points of
commonality is
really important and that and that one
is find
those precious precious moments either
way whether there's a god
and a next life and a soul or whether
we're on
we're on a rock in the middle of nowhere
one on a meaningless journey
either way at the end of the day um
finding those beautiful moments is what
it's all about well said
all right how about one more does god
exist
hell no
you mentioned a second ago you and i
don't get involved in this whole does
god exist or not
theism versus atheism conversation
because
it's ridiculous like you're not gonna
prove anything plus
it's not like this is a rational
argument you're not going to make a
rational
argument for the existence or
non-existence of god because
fundamentally faith is an emotion and
emotions
aren't really pervious to like you know
reason and data i always say like faith
is like love
like you don't love is just love like
you love someone
no one's gonna convince you to love
somebody you just do
or you don't and the same thing is true
about
faith but as you know pete just said
just a moment ago i think we got to be
ready for some doubt man
like one way or another whether you're a
believer or whether you are
a hardcore atheist i think either hell
yes or hell no
is probably the wrong answer to the
question
is there a god uh the right answer is
maybe i hear you a hundred percent and i
was just thinking as you were talking
about love
the analogy i always use is beauty
because
you're not gonna like i have this i'm
not i can't convince anyone that this is
beautiful
you know it's like oh i see this as
beautiful it's like i i see it as
repulsive
um but it is uh it has
it's beyond any kind of rationality it's
something you
experience it's something you feel or
not
is there beauty in the world hell yes
that was great well you guys keep these
questions coming we we love them we love
them we love them go to speakpipe.com
metaphysical milkshake we've got
questions we have
interactions with actual human beings
we'd love to get you involved have you
on the show hear your thoughts
and debate them furiously and make fun
of you so please
keep the calls coming
you know how to find us we're on socials
at reza aslan at
rayne wilson the show is on twitter at
metamilkpodcast
it's on instagram at metaphysical
milkshake and remember to follow
rate and review metaphysical milkshake
on apple podcasts please write the
little review
just take take a few seconds if you like
the show it helps us a great deal
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson
it is produced by safa samasa desd
harris lane
mick demaria hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold it was
additionally executive produced by goal
reese lucina
and daryush brazwella no it was produced
by amy estroy and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans
associate producers are jocelyn gonzalez
lindsey crowderwill
sarah pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby sandlin
[Music]
you're most famous for two things you're
a comically absurd height
ah that's not true he really is wayne
didn't know i was six six
dear listeners that is so not true i've
been watching your comedy for years and
i had
no idea you were a goliath yeah i missed
pause a door
you're the manute bowl of comedy people
who make doors go
surely no one could need more than this
[Music]
you